I mean Shapiro
the great privilege of introducing Doug
for the third of his Stimson lectures on
capitalism knowledge drives wealth just
before I say a few words about Doug just
to let everybody know that at the close
of today's proceedings there will be a
reception on the second floor to which
everybody is invited so I thought I
would tell you two things about done one
more generally about him and the other
more specifically relevant to today's
and yesterday's and the day before
lectures so the there are many
remarkable things about Doug but I think
in some ways the most remarkable thing
about him is the number of times he has
reinvented himself most academics sort
of find a recipe that works and they are
successful and you know relatively
Pavlovian thereafter they just keep
pecking away you know at the same thing
and they get as Doug said for the next
50 years they get fed so that's not that
Doug started his career writing a first
book which actually established almost
of the entire field there's political
consequences of electoral laws book was
was a field certainly a field redefining
book others had worked on this but he he
you know for decades that was this
standard reference and then he got bored
with that that general topic and it was
the in the in this late 50s early 1960s
the public choice movement had come
along and produced a number of very
important papers in the early public
choice literature on majority rule on
measures of party fragmentation some
with with other scholars but a number by
himself and he was thought to be a
rising star in the emerging field of
public choice in the 1960s
and then in 1970 in the 1970s John Rawls
published his theory of justice and
developed interest in normative
questions or explicitly normative
questions I think all of his work is
implicitly been normative and he wrote
some very important papers on on
distribution that have stood the test of
time as well
extremely well and then when I came
along here in the 1970s he was working
on the subject of equality eventually
published a book with a number of
younger colleagues and graduate students
called equality's which to this day
remains the best analytical treatment of
the subject of equality and then he got
bored with all that and what Stephen
didn't tell you on on Tuesday it wasn't
just that John Daniels called him up to
be chief administrator of the city which
he did but before that Doug took a leave
and Ashley ran the Daniels campaign for
mayor against the Italian dominated
machine and won and so and when he came
back to yell after his two years in the
city he came he went to som and he
decided to decide a public management
from the point of view of somebody with
all of that behind him that I've just
described and as a practitioner and not
content with that he spent the next
close to decade writing a monumental
book called city urbanism and it's end
which is is widely recognized in the
book on in the literature and urban
politics it's one of the best books but
also harkens back to all debates in
political science started by Bob Dole's
who governs in 1956 there had been a
series of books about power putting
what's the word it catalyzed by that
book all of which were based on studies
of New Haven and so Doug came back
to that power literature with city and I
think made some very important
contributions to that so he is and and
you and now he's been working for the
last several years on this book about
capitalism he has more than two hundred
thousand words already written I've seen
some chapters on knowledge and it's
again completely different from anything
he's done before and Betty perfectionist
that he is he will sandpaper and polish
and plain away until he has a definitive
statement to make on this subject which
I have absolutely no doubt he will so
that's that's dogging incredibly unusual
creative person made definitive
contributions to so many different
fields of political science then this
specific thing I wanted to say that's
relevant to this series of lectures that
he's giving now is that in 1975 he
published a very important paper the
American Political Science Review called
the limits of consensual decision and
this paper was a critique of Buchanan in
telex book the the calculus of consent
for which miu cannon was eventually
awarded a Nobel Prize in 1986 but they
didn't give it to talaq even though they
had written it together but in those
days it was unthinkable to give a Nobel
Prize to a political scientist even
though they have since given one to
Elinor Ostrom
nonetheless telic was not happy about
that but but Doug's paper the the the
calculus of consent the thesis of the
book was that we should set up
constitutional systems to bias the world
toward the status quo particularly
because if people have rights that they
think are very important to them it
should be difficult to change them and
so it was widely seen as a kind of
subtext of it as it
offense of the American system that Doug
has been criticizing in these lectures
but in that paper in that 1975 paper
Doug introduced the concept of utility
drift utility drift and by what he meant
by our utility drift is the following
that if you set up a system to bias
things toward the status quo the status
quo it sounds like it's something fixed
but actually it's not fixed the status
quo can drift and the utilities that
different people derive from the status
quo can change over time and so if you
think about making it very hard to
change things you might be able to
change some new status quo to which the
world has drifted since you put into
place your your institutional system to
make it hard to change the status quo
and so think of a couple of the examples
Doug gave in the last lecture one was
gun control well when the the Federalist
Papers were being written to get the
Constitution adopted in New York and
Virginia they had to make a promise that
there would be a bill of rights and
otherwise it was a condition for getting
for getting the Constitution adopted and
the wide expectation was that the Bill
of Rights would protect states rights
but Madison very concerned about a
resurgence of the anti-federalists power
said no and he rewrote the Bill of
Rights as individual rights not as
states rights and of course when he was
writing about individual rights the guns
we you know we had muskets but the
utility drift has been such that now we
have you know people say three hundred
and fifty million guns in America
Paolo's Andoni who's here somewhere
today reckons it's more like nine
hundred right
okay all right so this is not the world
that Madison was remotely contemplating
when he created an individual right to
bear arms protected by the Second
Amendment you know the the other one is
the other obvious one is environmental
regulation which Doug mentioned where
again there's been massive utility drift
in the status quo that our institutions
are now as stuck pointed out straining
at the margins to address so this is
just one example of how Doug's work over
the years gives us so many insights into
the sorts of things that he's talking
about today
I'm usually a critic of long
introductions but it seemed to me
sufficient he's warranted in this case
but now I will shut the sit down and
shut up and turn it over to duck welcome
thanks in three of my children are here
and I hope they believe all all right
this is what what I hope to do today and
it's mostly to celebrate capitalism as
an adventure in learning learning about
what works what doesn't what people can
be expected to pay for what they can't
what defeats disease what doesn't what
keeps a house warm at night at low cost
what doesn't so it's an accumulation of
knowledge and every new firm is a kind
of live experiment most fail and the few
succeeds spectacularly these this is the
list I don't know really why I put it up
in such detail but it begins with small
firms working on precision metal tools
an input to a particular kind of tools
called machine tools which are tools for
making machines they are tools in a
sense for making tools and the the best
known instance is the lathe which will
see an example of here in a minute the
concepts of accuracy and precision are
both in play here and they don't mean
the same thing at all this diagram from
Simon Winchester shows some you think of
these as bullets being aimed at the
middle of the target in the left hand
circle
the bullets are
we clustered and in the right place
there is accuracy and precision being in
the right place is accuracy precision is
having the story and sticking to it
the example in the in the middle is
precise but inaccurate and the one on
the right is imprecise and if you're if
you're truly in precise accuracy doesn't
even have a clear meaning precision
comes to mean both precision and
accuracy and it gets defined by a
tolerance when you make something you
guarantee let's say you say it's going
to be one inch in diameter it could be
up to 1.001 inches or 0.999 inches but
it's got to be in that narrow range and
those tolerances as the foundation of an
industrial economy occurs those
tolerances get thinner and thinner more
zeros point zero zero zero six or seven
zeros one would be a tolerance on fine
machinery for a watch or an aircraft
engine another another pair of concepts
have to do with reliability and
availability availability means
constructing say a factory in such a way
that the tool needed for a given
operation will be available when it's
needed and won't be in the way when it
isn't needed and reliability means that
it will function many many times without
fail by you all know what reliability
means it means working correctly many
many times in a row as illustrated by
the
right here the and a this gantry crane
is used all over the world every harbour
which has has any freight traffic will
have many gantry gantry cranes and they
have a certain reliability a pretty good
reliability would be a hundred thousand
straight operations on average without a
failure and even better would be five
hundred thousand or a million and the
progression in machine tools would stand
behind tools we use directly has made
possible higher and higher degrees of
reliability not always achieved as on
the right and sometimes catastrophic ly
not achieved and reliability is an
economic question but not just an
economic question everyone in this room
has repeatedly better life on the
reliability of Pratt & Whitney aircraft
engines and Boeing 737 flying systems so
those are background concepts and now
let's look at real people and real firms
who made extraordinary contributions
without ever being famous in the sense
of movies or newspapers the steam engine
the first steam engine well the very
first steam engine was around 60 ad a
man named hero of Alexandria created a
spinning think of a doughnut a metal
doughnut filled with water and heated
from below
with nozzles that sprayed steam out so
you heat this thing and the steam makes
it spin at a very high speed and the
ancients were they didn't they never
thought of using it to do work but they
thought it was very fun to look at and
I'm sure it was the the first modern
steam engine was the new common engine
1712 the the Bolton and what improvement
of that engine came in the 1780s and
modern high-pressure steam engines first
emerged in the year 1800 the steam
engine drove the machine tool industry
because it created an enormous market
for precisely designed and highly
reliable machinery which could be driven
by steam power
Henry Maudsley I it's spelled Maudsley
but I'm told by people who speak the
King's English as opposed to our English
emily mau dsl a wise spells monthly as
if it were an e this guy was quite
remarkable no formal education went to
work as a powder monkey at age 12 grew
to be six feet two and a five specimen
of a man had a long career designing
machinery and hiring and firing the best
young people in Great Britain to help in
that task the direct caught his direct
contributions they were actually about
half a dozen but the one that was most
important was the ability to manufacture
in screws so that they were precisely
alike one after another thousands at a
time what do I expect you to do about
those I have some theory about how those
are pertinent to this but the thing
about them is that they are precisely
the same the motion of the lathe the
lathe is doing two things at once it's
rotating this way and the cutting point
is moving this way so that as a cutting
point moves and the lathe turns and
moves the object being worked it cuts a
kind of barber pole pattern on the metal
and that you can change the pitch of
that barber barber pole cut to make any
particular kind of screw and then you
can repeat it once you automate it in
the machine you can have the machinery
repeat it thousands indeed millions of
times over and over again and the cheap
bolts which I bought a few weeks ago at
Lowe's are made they're actually made by
a different process but they were made
possible by mods Lee's mods Lee's
invention there's there's a machine
that's working
ah the royal one of the interesting
things about early capitalism is that
the customer of first resort was often
the government in Britain it was the
Royal Navy and the product a ship of the
line like this one would require what we
call pull pulleys and they call blocks
they're wooden objects and they were
maybe about like that like the one
pictured beneath the bird on the right
and they had to be precisely alike and
replicable so that a sailor who got
familiar with using one copy could use
any copy that the Navy had and the there
was a highly automated Factory at
Portsmouth which supplied the whole
Royal Navy and which relied on Maudsley
and his shop for every detail of their
work Samuel Bentham mentioned at the top
of this chart brother of the famous
utilitarian philosopher I think Sam was
probably the smarter of the two actually
was in charge of that operation at
Portsmouth the American story is
parallel and well behind the British
story the Brits at the beginning of in
the year let's say 1790 1818 10:00 the
technology available in Britain was
almost across-the-board superior to what
was available in North America and
that's part of how colonialism is is
planned to work indeed the colonial the
colonial economy was for the home
country to do the high value high
value-added manufacturing and the rude
on the other side of the ocean to grow
the grow the plants and distill cheap
rum and stuff like that this is the hero
of my story in all three lectures is
Hamilton whom I regard as head and
shoulders above the rest of the founders
he was not as good a politician he was a
he was truth to tell a bad politician is
that your judgment in an inept
politician and he had hideous judgment
about intimate relations with women
otherwise everybody wants something
right at a genius he was the first
secretary of the Treasury and said about
to catch up with the Brits and there are
two ways of catching up with a superior
economy one is to invent stuff and a
quicker method is to steal stuff and
Hamilton stole stuff or induced others
to steal not physical objects but the
plan and design of physical objects the
the machine that machine the arc right
water frame which doesn't look like much
to my 21st century eyes was the central
mechanism in producing cheap cotton
cloth on a massive scale powered by
water and powered by water even a
hundred years after the first steam
engine which is another story about
technologies actually get absorbed into
real life quite slowly and a general
purpose technology like a steam engine
took on average about a century to
become working in in routine ways
Hamilton
worked with a guy
name ten stocks who was his deputy and
Treasury and the the federal government
wasn't a big thing in in the first round
right there were about twelve employees
total in the Department of the Treasury
and Hamilton did most of his work for
himself without delegating to others but
he delegated the Cox the task of
capturing British trade secrets related
to textile manufacturing and Samuel
Slater shown on the right many decades
after the story were telling after he
had emigrated to America and become the
founder of Slater Mills which were an
extremely important Rhode Island company
manufacturing cotton cloth using
technology which he stole by working
directly for Arkwright under the
indirect supervision of the secretary of
the treasury that's this is a 1978 photo
of one of the mills that was part of
Slate this later
Mills operation in Wolff them
machine tools and textile manufacturing
and so on in contemplation of an economy
based on steam engines but we're not
using steam engines they are expensive
and relatively unreliable compared to
water flowing through a river and that
made river towns how many of you have
been through or visited the town Windsor
Vermont anybody who goes very far into
Vermont has to pass the pass I think
it's exit eight on i-90 one which is
there's a sign that says Windsor
birthplace of Vermont
and but it doesn't mention Robbins &
Lawrence machine tool Factory it's now
called an armory MIT actually took over
the preservation of it and manages it's
a little museum I went there last summer
three times full of early 19th century
machinery of a very high caliber and
Robbins & Lawrence was influential
throughout northeastern United States as
we'll see in just a second
there's here's a chart Robinson Lawrence
is at about 9:00 p.m. on the clock face
there to the left then they're located
in Windsor because it it is a river town
on the Connecticut River and they had
constructed a canal which created a
sluice way which made made it feasible
for Robbins & Lawrence to conduct quite
heavy manufacturing in that seemingly
isolated location the monastery's these
charts is not part of our our object but
it is worth looking at at the arrows the
arrows represent influence typically
when a given artisan moved from one firm
to another or when a firm licensed a
design to another firm the this these
slide these charts were all done by
Joseph W Rowe who was a junior faculty
member in the Yale Sheffield scientific
school and published in 1915 and it it
it's three
it's a it's a beautiful piece of
sociological and technological research
Eli Whitney of course was located here
in New Haven we will hear more about him
momentarily Smith & Wesson became a
world important manufacturer of high
quality weaponry Winchester Repeating
Arms its peak located just west of the
Yale campus at its peak employed 26,000
people think about 26,000 full-time
equivalents the campus well Sam you ran
that campus as science bar after they
left was something like a little city
unto itself and all these connections
are linked back in ways that ro and
others can trace out to the very early
perfection of machine tools which made
possible everything they did surplus
slides my fault interchangeability
that's what these bolts and that's there
for the so-called American system is
that I can no I can't put two bolts
together I pick one bolt and and one
knot I can be perfectly sure that any
nut will fit any bolt within the same
sized framework and the same thread
pitch and that that's a huge element in
the wealth of any industrial society
today is widespread interchangeability
of machine parts the question
who perfected that and how it got to be
in the so-called American system it is
quite interesting it was invented by
somebody named Block B loc in in France
let somebody just push the yeah
push the button Jefferson when Jefferson
was in Paris he went to an exhibition
where the the where LeBlanc invited
people to at random pick parts of a gun
lock out of bins and put them together
and Jefferson was blown away by the fact
that he could as he put it at hazard
picked Parts Part A and Part B and fit
them together and by golly they worked
exactly right and so Jefferson writes
home to I think John J saying this is
something we've got to figure out how to
copy some writers including row of Yale
Sheffield think that Whitney perfected
interchangeability others notably Simon
Winchester say dreadful things about Eli
Whitney and there is a little evidence
Bill Brown and anybody in the room know
Bill Brown yeah lots of people he knows
more about today's topic certainly than
I do and runs that you I Whitney Museum
quite brilliantly and when I asked him
about this he said well there are file
marks all over the Whitney gun locks and
the file marks aren't there because the
things fit interchangeably
so there's probably a degree of truth in
what winchester says that's enough of
interchangeability i
I could talk about the Enfield rifle but
[Laughter]
that's true well it's English but made
with American machine tools this was at
the time of the Civil War American
machine tools were being shipped all
over the world because they were the
best and most precise available now a
very different story this one involves
learning - and a fair degree of
chicanery it and it begins as I hint in
the slide it begins in the Yale
chemistry department with a young
Dartmouth graduate having been given a
vial of crude oil by a professor at
Dartmouth and the guy who had a de cette
was thinking that there might be some
money to be made in oil and and was
interested in finding out where if there
is money to be made he could acquire
quite a lot of it and he he brought his
specimen to Benjamin Silliman jr. for
whom Selman College and a great many
other things around Yale are named and
Silman wrote an elaborate report it's in
it the original is in the binary library
to this day what he did was prescient he
distilled the crude oil
using a device like the one pictured on
the left here to find it the fractional
components of it which would boil off at
different temperatures and he told the
young man from Dartmouth that he was
onto something that there were powerful
opportunities here he focused mainly on
combustibles that could be used as fuel
in particular kerosene and naphtha which
in the case of standard oil were the
pivotal products that made standard oil
what it became the fractionating tower
of a modern oil refinery is a big
apparatus almost perfectly analogous to
the laboratory device that gentleman
used in 1850 oh yeah in in the late
1850s they hired the gentlemen pictured
here Edwin Drake Edwin dray and they
hired him here in New Haven matter of
fact Edwin Drake was an unemployed
railway conductor and his principal
qualification for the job the job was in
western Pennsylvania where they had come
to suspect there was something called
oil creek and they had come to suspect
that there might be oil near and they
sent this guy out there to drill a hole
and see if there was and the the reason
they chose him they were short of
capital and they as an unemployed
railway conductor he had a railway pass
oh wow to reach western pennsylvania
free of charge and so they picked him on
that basis and they were lucky he was
pretty he was pretty ingenious and
persistent and he drilled a hole it kept
collapsing and he figured out how to use
a metal pipe as casement to prevent it
falling in on itself and indeed did
strike oil near Titusville Titusville
Pennsylvania which I've never seen
anybody here ever been to Titusville Wow
this is an exciting place okay
so the initial story is the the initial
challenge the oil came in and came in in
pretty good quantity they're producing
three or four thousand barrels each
barrel is 42 gallons per day and the
question was what to do with it how to
get it to some market and barrels were
the first answer you can see a huge
barrel yard in the background there and
tankage the round the round thing
lower-right was a temporary solution
very temporary and the key the key
players in this early story or Teamsters
Teamsters running ordinary wagons pulled
by horses and the Teamsters quickly
figured out that they had a really good
piece of leverage with which to extract
high prices for hauling the hauling the
oil to the nearest railhead
you can read that as well as I can the
interesting part is $1 per barrel mile
as a charge would be killer no way that
that could be sustained flat boats on
oil Creek of course we're part of the
workaround but the real workaround was a
pipeline a two and a half inch diameter
pipeline which is described here at some
length the the Teamsters tore up the
first version of it as you could imagine
they might and an armed guard was
ultimately required to protect the thing
moving oil 80 barrels an hour across two
and a half miles to the nearest railhead
oil production and consumption
accelerates very quickly in the years
after the Civil War as suggested here
with about 10 million barrels by 1873
and indeed by 1873 Standard Oil was
already a company and and a suddenly
very important company
I've already pretty much said that what
that slide says john d rockefeller and
the rise of Standard Oil is the
remainder of the story a the vertical
for petroleum a vertical meaning the set
of processes from the beginning when it
is in the ground that nobody knows
where to find it to the point where it
is in a container and we can pour it
into a lamp and use the kerosene to
illuminate a room so you read the chart
bottom to top and Rockefeller stationed
himself in Cleveland right in the middle
of this vertical at the point of
refining the oil so he starts with crude
oil and ends up with kerosene naphtha
and other products replicating on a vast
scale
the tiny operation which professor
Selman had carried out decades earlier
at Yale Rockefeller was his father was a
crook crook and a bigamist to complete
families operating unbeknownst to one
another and Rockefeller there was a
certain certain cunning about john d
rockefeller and he looked at this story
and said where is the leverage and
thinking back to the Teamsters at
Titusville saw that it was in
transportation and so he did his scheme
involved collaborating with people
operating railroads to gain a huge and
utterly unfair advantage over his
competitor the this is the chessboard
around 1870 the oil country the triangle
at the west is the oil country in
Pennsylvania Cleveland in Ohio on the
edge of the great length of shore of the
Great Lakes and Pittsburgh not very far
away and then the eastern parts of the
board are New York New Jersey on the one
hand
in Philadelphia on the other Rockefeller
seized on the to transit vectors shown
in green here and allied himself with
the railroads to create an advantage
which would [ __ ] literally [ __ ] if
not destroy anyone who was shipping oil
at full fare on the same railroads yeah
the railroads are in frantic competition
and they need what they need long trains
full of paying paying cargo people are
fine but the real money is in Freight
and the idea of a freight train with a
hundred cargo cars of oil was the
perfect thing from the point of view of
of the railroads oh this is the guy next
slide
young man Rockefeller starts out at age
16 in Cleveland without a job becomes a
an accountant and actually a very
capable one and his ability to calculate
costs very very shrewdly was a big part
of his eventual story he and an
Englishman named MB Clark started a
commission business on the docks in
Cleveland where they dealt in fresh
produce and that within two years they
were grossing four hundred and fifty
thousand dollars which was a lot of
money a lot more money than it sounds
like would be calculated well into the
tens of millions in today's dollars
he then partner
up with this guy Andrews in a refining
and oil refinery there are 25
competitors in the same part of
Cleveland because it's a perfect
shipping point towards the west and from
the oil country and John Dee is the
shrewdest the toughest and the most
aggressive among them yes
why Standard Oil was formed in January
of 1870 that's the whole the whole
contract in hand script on the screen
but Standard Oil was pretty much one of
26 cleveland refineries until you began
to tamper with the shipping rates and
they john dee engineered the creation of
the South improvement company some
people try to clean it up and say
southern but it's not southern it's
south it was a shell company the Charter
had been approved by the Pennsylvania
Railroad for an entirely different
purpose but Tom Scott was in on the deal
and was the political boss of
Pennsylvania at the time and helped John
Dee to repurpose that charter to create
an alliance with several railroads as
indicated in the slide a feature and he
put not himself but a loyal henchman
henchman in charge of the South
improvement and from Ma one provision of
it was that the way bills for all
shipments of oil on any of these
railroads from any producer or consumer
would pass through the desk of this
henchman of of Rockefellers so that
Rockefeller could chart what everybody
was doing or trying to do in his
business with one data set it's a
remarkable edge to have now drawbacks
and rebates rebates were there was a
nominal price and the law would say that
a common carrier a railroad that is open
for business
everyone has to have a posted rate and
charge the same rate to everyone and and
the drawbacks and the rebates were ways
around that the rebate meant I pay you
the full price and then you give me a
kickback reducing the effective price in
the ways I won't repeat the the math on
the board a drawback is a nastier item
even than that a drawback means if
you're in in the deal with the southern
South improvement company and you ship
oil for another company not included in
the south then you will pay me a fee for
every barrel of that oil you care so as
they carry more of the competitors oil
more more dollars are transferred to the
southern improvement company and thence
to Standard Oil yeah yeah his pitch to
the 25 competitors in Cleveland was
pretty simple he was the only member of
the South improvement he went to all of
them and said feel free to compete if
you think you can do it and they would
all know they couldn't do it uh and he
said well I will welcome you to join
Standard Oil by selling your plant to me
I'll have an appraiser come around and
we will
offer you a price and the price of price
will be what we estimate you could make
using that plant on your own against our
impossible competition and I sure enough
they all sold not quite off all but
there were a few who just stuck it out
to the bitter end then and died with
their boots on but he became a
monopolist on Cleveland refining and
wasn't content with that he of course
wanted to be a monopolist nationally the
we don't have time to follow that story
out to the end there are wonderful books
about Standard Oil the tipping point is
the Sherman Antitrust Act of 1890 which
had the purpose its primary purpose was
to try to curtail standard oil's near
monopoly on the national market it had
no such effect in in the first 15 years
after 1890 but a lawsuit was filed in
nineteen seven the Justice Department
actually filed it and it was United
States versus Standard Oil it was
decided ultimately at the Supreme Court
in 1911 William Howard Taft another Yale
connected person was important in the in
the narrative and they broke Standard
Oil into 34 companies and the effect on
Rockefeller would you think devastating
now it made him actually quite a lot
richer because the the the split up
companies were more efficient in what
they did then the big company had been
and
he never lacked for health again in his
life I mean the stories get shorter on
the slides fewer as we go fear not I
don't want to stand between you and a
drink upstairs Henry Ford was a
scoundrel
a very clever scoundrel and an interest
interesting man when I call him a
scoundrel because of his vicious
anti-semitism he was way off the charts
he was well beyond the ordinary
garden-variety anti-semitism of his time
he was also really good at organizing
production and the Model T which was I
think his eighth or ninth attempt at
manufacturing an automobile begins in
nineteen eight and creates the first
instance of mass affluence in America
American economy I'll show you I'll show
you why first this is an interesting
fact Ford didn't have secrets Lord
didn't generally use patents he invited
journalists and engineers from other
companies to come to his plant and look
at everything and write about it as they
chose my source in working on this was a
journal called American mechanic which
we have in Sterling library from the
period and every few months in the years
after 1980 there's an elaborate story on
how Ford makes a brake cylinder or a
magneto or whatever else and so he was
not hoarding knowledge we did and
eventually
came back to bite him because Alfred
Sloan and others at General Motors were
able to use the information edge they
had about four to their own advantage
copying the best stuff and leaving the
rest to Ford this is knowing by learning
by doing and it it sounds a little smug
because it is he says I knew how to
build a car and I built it and the Model
T was quite remarkable he built 15
million of them and they changed the
face of American life in almost every
respect not every respect for the better
this was a highly regimented assembly
line where the the car was actually a
six story plan the car starts on the top
the top floor and works its way down
like this until it's ready to be shipped
out I have beautiful slides about the
plant but we don't have time here's what
what's remarkable about for in on
January well let me tell it tell the
story better in nineteen eight the
workforce hates the Ford plant they hate
their jobs they hate them for a good
reason
they are if any of you seen the movie
modern times where you have to keep up
with the assembly line
we're Charlie Chaplin is it going around
fist it was that it was brutal and
turnover was on the order of 50 percent
a year of workers just quit it I'm not
going to do this and Ford was then
paying
about two dollars and fifty cents a day
and on the first of January 1914 he
announced a five-dollar
wage the five-dollar workday it outraged
everybody else in the manufacturing
trades the effect was to give him
enormous ly privileged access to
whatever workers he wanted and he had
done the math and knew that it worked
the chart here if you look at the
right-hand column how many days do I
have to work at the Ford plant to
accumulate the retail price of the
product and that starts out I'm sorry
not the right-hand column then the
second from the right hand column wage
days needed to buy a Model T starts out
well over three hundred days a solid
year of effort and ends up under two
months
so the real pay level is improved to a
staggering degree and it's two things
happening at once one is that the price
of the car is falling from 850 down to
310 and the wage late wage level is
going up from two and change to six and
the third thing is that the labor
content of the cars is getting less and
less and less the plant is more and more
efficient in the use of labor so they
start at over a hundred and fifty seven
days I have the five hundred and
fifty-seven as the number for 1912 so
all I can do is guess one nineteen eight
would have been but my guess is it was
probably close to two hundred days and
they get that down to about fifty man
days per automobile which is pretty high
by Bonner
standards but was extremely low then the
effect was to empower working people to
buy products which had in the very
recent past been entirely unavailable to
the likes of factory workers and that is
a signal contribution to the wealth of
this nation now we're going to look at
what an hour's work will buy in some
standard commodities these are
computations rigorously and carefully
carried out by our student Peter luff
who is operating the his hand operating
the automation slide this is the wage
cost in in time of a dozen eggs in 1900
we're at about about a day of work an
hour of work sorry got yeah an hour of
work to buy a dozen eggs and buy the
present time we are down to a few very
few minutes can you give it a number
Peter uh negligible negligible interval
now beef is different
beef gets to be fairly cheap by 1900 but
there is no systematic downward trend in
beef prices over the 20th century yeah
cool a big bump in the 20s and
rapid decline during the Depression and
it's been pretty flat since the Nixon
era I would say yeah sugar have a Meyer
sugar trust notwithstanding gets to be
pretty cheap it's an it gets to be
pretty cheap though the retail price of
sugar in the United States is way above
world prices and that's due to they have
a Meijer it's really cheap compared to
the American past but not really cheap
compared to the present in the rest of
the world aluminum is a great story
before 1886 aluminum was a precious
metal comparable to gold or platinum in
value and two people at once one of them
an undergraduate at Oberlin College
named Hall invented a way of using
electrolysis with electrical current to
extract aluminum from bauxite and the
price began to fall and has fallen ever
since in about ten days ago I checked
the London Metal Exchange and a metric
ton which is about 2200 pounds was
selling for $1,700 in change and you can
what we do we make well that soda can I
have on the desk there is probably about
a cent and a half's worth of aluminum
it's a very cheap product today American
capitalist inequality in income and net
worth I'm not going to talk long about
this and I don't have the answers
what answer is there's a hell of a lot
of inequalities yeah let's put up a
curve
this curve was devised empirically by
vilfredo pareto an italian engineer
polymath and economist the horizontal
scale measures income from none to off
the chart and the vertical scale
represents a number of people at each
income level it is an asymmetric curve
with a long tail on the right that is
the high end and a short tail if any on
the bottom or left hand side the median
household this is the the median splits
the distribution into two equal sized
groups so there are roughly a majority
on each side of the yellow bar and the
mean is well to the right of the median
why because of the big numbers on the
right hand tail the big numbers which
pull the mean up okay one the quick
interpretation of this is that a
majority of Americans have an income
below the national average it's
somewhere in the high 50% maybe 58 59
percent of American households have less
than the average income and that's an
annoying political fact right I mean
that's awkward and it's true of every
capitalist country taxes can can modify
it and we may be about to modify it
but it is a pretty stubbornly repeated
distribution story about market
economies we could I if we had time we
could go through 50 countries and do the
empirics and they would all look more or
less like this chart the bottom half the
the current the current political debate
is about to be focused on this book just
published a few days ago called the
triumph of injustice how the rich dodge
taxes and and how to make them pay by
two French economist who teach at
Berkeley and I'll give you I'll give you
their numbers in just a second the let's
do their numbers here we are they say
the way to think about the country is
having four classes the rich the upper
middle class the middle class and the
working class most of the fight is about
the working class and the their estimate
is that the mean not median mean income
of people in the lower half of the
American income distribution is eighteen
thousand five hundred dollars per worker
so if you have two workers it's thirty
seven if you have one worker it's
eighteen five
I think eighteen five is probably wrong
I think it's probably wrong by eight or
ten thousand dollars which is a lot but
it's still a pretty small number and the
the fight which is now playing out in
the Democratic primaries is focused
mainly on
at bottom half and our government is not
well set up for responding to that and
what the my own take goes something like
this
there are things I that I call merit
goods that I think everybody has a right
to have one is nutritious food
another is decent health care not not
concierge health care but health care
and another is decent shelter and I
think it is the government's business to
make sure that everybody near the bottom
of the income distribution has civilized
access to those merit goods one way to
do it is with transfer payments and
people cash and say go find it another
is with for example food stamps and
similar programs the food side of this
the fact that about ten percent of
Americans are food insecure is a
disgrace this is the most productive
agricultural economy the world has ever
known
and it is beyond embarrassing that there
are people well I I tell the story of
having visited visited a New Haven
household this is some some time ago
where it was a four generation household
with thirteen members and the
great-grandmother the matriarch of the
household the owner of the place had a
chain wrapped around the refrigerator
and threw the handle and slept at night
with the chain around her with the key
to the refrigerator around her neck and
I think that's
that's not okay I'm a big believer in
capitalism and a big believer in the
market freedoms that make it so
inventive one lat one last oh here we go
well the first point I've already made
and the the great wealth of a capitalist
republic like ours is in the practical
knowledge that has been generated in the
ten generations up to now and will be
generated in the next ten and ten
generations going forward god-willing
is the american republic ideally suited
to deal with the problems we face no not
even close we are a long way from well
equipped to deal with the fundamental
decisions that are implicit in the facts
I've been reviewing is it well worth our
valuable time to explore further I think
so in fact I think so with some some
passion what the founders got right what
Alexander Hamilton most of all got right
was the idea that perpetual learning is
the core value of a free society and our
own is an imperfect embodiment of that
ambition but it's a pretty robust and
healthy and resilient version of it in
which I think we can quite properly
rejoice thanks very much and we're ready
for drinks
[Applause]
[Music]